uh coming out of the Bronx give me kind
of you you said 50 is your favorite ever
your goat 50 said my favorite rapper DMX
my favorite rapper I love Eminem too
like well shout out to you know it's
crazy because I do feel like what is
dope about you is you're extremely
vulnerable and when like cuz I've
watched a lot of your interviews I
watched your Vlad interview you're very
honest about like your life you've had
you know obviously a very very um
interesting come up to say the least but
I think that you have kind of like that
DMX vulnerability about you that not a
lot of artists have these days cuz I
feel like when I was like listening to
DMX as I felt like I felt his pain and
[__] you know what I'm saying like is
that important for you to like make sure
you kind of like very very upfront about
everything in the bars and your life and
all that yeah I'm like a open book you
feel me I just want somebody to talk to
for real so I just do it in my music
like hoping like somebody understand me
you feel me and I see like a lot of
people relate to me and understand like
growing up people didn't really relate
to me they say oh she's depressed and
stuff like that you know what I mean but
I'm just happy like to just speak about
it cuz they be like oh she's depressed
she's crazy D no what if I'm just sad
you know what I mean what if I just need
somebody to talk to you feel me like
yeah I'm going through [__] my mom just
died obviously I'm sad you know what I
mean so it's just like putting it in
music everybody relate and everybody can
feel and I feel like I'm not the only
one so it's like people be like yeah she
makes me feel like I'm not the only one
but really they make me feel like I'm
not the only one you feel what I'm
saying yeah for you like do you have you
have you had fans reach out to you and
be like yo you kind of like help me get
through this cuz I I watched one of your
interviews and I was just like God damn
like this is so crazy cuz there has to
be people out there who don't have the
means or like the you know the ability
to kind of like vent to somebody you
know what I'm saying who maybe watching
interview like yours or listen to some
of your records and like really can't
relate like have you had fans reach out
to you like that yeah a lot of my fans
reach out to me they just be like you
inspir me so much some people be like I
wanted to commit suicide and they be
like they heard my song suicide
awareness and it made them want to keep
going that's do and then just young
girls around the world just be like I
look up to you scar like I could relate
to you yeah and that makes me keep going
believe it or not that's like damn like
people really need even if it's like one
person one person but it be a lot no but
I'm saying like that's it's crazy cuz if
you could affect one person's life let
alone however many you know thousands
you know what I mean yeah even the even
the [__] I used to beat
up they be saying scar you want me to
keep going shout out to them yeah were
there a lot of women used to beat up I
used to [__] these [__] up well for
what though for disrespect to me various
reasons various reasons various reasons
but you know what anybody you regret
[__] up like damn I I really was
tripping that day I really that didn't
deserve a ass beating you know I feel
like everybody deserved what they had
coming okay so it's safe to say you're
nice with your hands yeah yeah uhhuh you
ever have you ever took the L on the
other side of I got beat up I got beat
up a lot of times on a one on one or a
jump I got beat up on one on ones many
times and it's always I'm always
fighting the big [__] I'm never
fighting no little [__] the BBWs yeah
no I'm just talking about big [__]
like like WNBA like bigger than me see
how I'm big Rebecca Lobo who's that uh
she's played for the Liberty back in the
day but yeah even the [__] I beat up
even the [__] that broke my heart they
be proud of me now
today uh you how many times have you had
your heart
broken three times three yeah how old
are you
22 that's not terrible that's not too
bad um what was the mo like for you like
was it
cheating this dude left me for a white
girl oh that's rough when I was in job
corpse damn Hey listen I'm white and I
don't even [__] with white women so I my
wife's Mexican my baby mom is
Mexican I I I've never ever ptok in the
in the white women so yeah he's tripping
the one thing you know listen the one
thing about white women though is like
all my friends like I have a lot of
black friends to date white chicks and
like for the most part um they are very
like uh they're they're the most
gullible idiotic women of all time like
I wish I wish I had it in me to date
someone who reminded me of my sister or
my aunt or something I like white
[__] they fun yeah they're fun and
gullible and kind of you know God bless
them you know they uh they definitely
sign the tax money right over you know
what I'm
saying they sure do um so so that was
was that the last guy who broke your
heart the last dude that broke my
heart was a dude from Jersey but I'm
over that now for real for real in real
life I don't even talk to these [__]
no more wow I can't even walk with them
no more